[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois dans cette édition
le l'astronaute français michel tognini
qui publie un café dans l'espace il fait
partie des 10 français qui sont allés
dans l'espace il y est allé deux fois
une fois avec les russes une fois avec
les américains il était devenu ensuite
chef du centre des astronautes européens
de l' agence spatiale européenne
c'est lui qui a recruté thomas pesquet
mais commençons par une image celle que
vous avez choisie pour illustrer ce
début de xxième siècle michel theuil min
la voici
alors qu'est ce qu'elle représente pour
nous pour moi c'est la vue de la terre
lorsque nous sommes sur la lune et cette
image et exprime le fait que nous allons
passer une soixantaine d'années à voler
autour de la terre à une altitude basse
de l'ordre de 400 km mais maintenant on
va commencer à faire des plans pour
s'éloigner un peu plus pour revenir sur
la lune d'une façon différente avec une
station autour de la lune et avec des
missions plus longues
autour de la lune alors vous justement
vous avez vous êtes pilote d'essai au
départ pilote de chasse a passé le
concours de recrutement des spationautes
en 1985 vous aviez 35 ans à ce moment là
qu'est ce que vous espériez
parce qu'en 85 c'est plutôt un creux
dans l'histoire de la conquête spatiale
on a fini on en a fini avec la mission
apollo on en a fini avec la lune
qu'est ce qu'on espère en 85 du côté de
l'espace alors en 85 du côté des espaces
et en europe via le programme permet ce
qui est une navette spatiale européenne
qui aurait dû être lancé par la fusée
ariane 5 est ce programme est un
programme assez complexe avec un avion
hypersonique qui va décoller comme une
charge utile au dessus de la fusée
ariane 5 mais qui va se poser comme un
planeur hypersonique et pour cela il
fallait le valider des périodes d'essai
et donc moi je me suis porté volontaire
comme pilote d'essais pour le programme
hermès donc c'était vraiment une grosse
activité au niveau français et européen
hollande hermès il ya mille candidats
à peu près à ce moment là vous parlez
vous raconter dans votre livre un café
dans l'espace pour raconter l'épreuve du
tabouret que vous pouvez nous raconter
ce que c'est que les preuves du tabouret
parce qu'elle al'air déterminant au
teint hâlé dit à rien parce qu'elle est
éliminatoire en fait chaque test vous
passez et éliminatoires c'est dire qu'à
chaque test la moitié est éliminé il
reste que moitié donc ifs
le but du jeu c'est de rester dans la
bonne moitié et ce qu'est ce que t'as
bourret en ont ils assez dur parce que
le tabouret ne ressemble pas à grand
chose
c'est à tous à l'ap un tabouret tout ça
qui va tourner autour d'un axe vertical
dont vous tourner autour de vous et
toutes les cinq secondes il faut baisser
le buste vers le bas que leur remontée
vers le haut
et au bout de quelques secondes vous
commencez à avoir le mal de l'espace le
mas des transports de façon assez
violente vous à l'impression d'avoir
deux diagonales qui vous tirent dans le
cerveau ça fait quand même assez mal et
moi j'ai commencé avant les premiers
symptômes au bout de 30 secondes et je
devais tenir huit minutes dont je me
suis battu par rapport à moi-même pour
tenir trente secondes une minute une
minute trente deux minutes après j'ai
dit je vais essayer d'aller jusqu'à 4
minutes
je n'étais pas sûr de rien jusqu'au bout
j'ai essayé de ralentir mon mouvement
j'ai essayé de respirer le plus possible
du vent j'ai utilisé toutes les méthodes
que je connaissais de relaxation
possible pour arriver à me à me détendre
et j'ai réussi les 8 minutes et de ceux
de ce moment là je sais que j'étais dans
la peau de moitié vous allez vous
retrouver à la cité des étoiles à moscou
avec jean loup chrétien qui est le
premier qui est parti dans l'espace le
premier français lacie la cité des
étoiles pour quelqu'un qui aspire à
partir dans l'espace j'imagine que c'est
c'est comme arrivé à hollywood quand on
veut être acteur alors c'est hollywood
lui tu vas sur beaucoup plus monastique
c'est un endroit qui est un une base
militaire qui est à une heure de moscou
avec très peu de très très peu de
distraction vous avez quand même une
base aérienne à l'intérieur une zone
opérationnelle
où sont les simulateurs et donc vous
passez le matin
jusqu'au soir à étudier puis après vous
avez vous passé des examens et après
vous passez au simulateur mais comme
distraction vous avez très peu de choses
à vous avez vraiment un petit magasin
qui vend peu de choses et puis vous avez
un cinéma qui ouvre qui ouvre une fois
tous les quinze jours avec un vieux
films la télévision était en noir et
blanc des trois chênes à l'époque je
crois c'est un brûleur et 7,50 vous y
allez la première rue basse et l'urss
c'était un petit peu difficile je pense
par rapport à ce que je connaissais en
france mais bon c'était le prix à payer
pour aller côtoyer les étoiles donc j'ai
payé ce prix là vous vous dites dans
votre ligne d'ailleurs que les
américains sont dans un tout autre atout
le tout autre mode de vie plus libre au
fond d'un contrat et bouby - la nasa un
vous le vous le raconter aussi ils sont
acharnés de travail mais quand même pour
les astronautes j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus cool c'est plus relax et à
dire que vous avez le droit d'habiter ou
vous voulez vous pour éviter à côté de
la nasa vous pouvez habiter à une heure
de la nasa ou est ce que vous voulez y a
pas d'organisation spéciale et puis même
le l'emploi du temps il est quand même
assez flexible chez américains parce que
vous avez quelques courts qui sont
obligatoires mais après c'est à vous
d'organiser votre entraînement demande
et des cours supplémentaires demandées
des séances de simulateur demandé à
travailler sur les points sur lesquels
vous ne vous sentez pas vraiment au
point
alors que je les ruses tout effet
automatiquement systématiquement par la
cellule d'entraînement de la cité des
étoiles
après la cité des étoiles vous allez
être qualifié vous allez partir dans
l'espace pour la première fois en 92
là ça n'est plus l'urss mais c'est
toujours baïkonour et baïkonour
j'imagine que là aussi ces mythologies
quand on arrive à baïkonour
baikonour c'est un sentiment un peu un
peu mixte parce qu'effectivement c'est
encore une fois un endroit un peu
désertique avec uniquement le centre
spatial à part le centre spatial et les
gens qui travaillent pour le spatial
il n'y a pas grand chose mais il ya
quand même toute l'histoire derrière il
ya yaka garine que derrière il ya titoff
que derrière ilya leonov et vous êtes
accompagné moi j'étais accompagné là bas
par alexis léonov qui m'a quittée avec
moi pour m'aider jusqu'au jusqu'aux
dernières minutes donc rappelé qu'ils
avaient merinov c'est le premier homme
qui est sortie la première sortie
extravéhiculaire il a d'ailleurs eu du
mal à revenir à rentrer sa combinaison
avec considérablement gonflé il
n'arrivait plus à rentrer mais c'est un
personnage évidemment légendaire
légendaire et puis j'étais ami avec lui
il était extrêmement humain était
rassurant il y donnait les bons mots il
dédramatise est un petit peu le la
tristesse qu'on peut avoir quand on est
un peu inquiet par rapport à l'espace
donc c'est quelqu'un qui avait un boost
incroyable et que qu'il a il accompagne
et pratiquement toutes les missions
bekono bon surtout en cours d'eau michel
tonini
vous insistez sur le fait à quel point
c'est important pour vous dans un café
dans l'espace vous insistez sur le fait
d'apprendre le russe
j'imagine que effectivement c'est la
base quand on va partir avec des russes
mais vous savoir le russe mais est-ce
que ça dépasse un motif d'inquiétude
supplémentaire de se dire qu'on va être
dans une aventure quand même incroyable
et quand même dangereuse dans une langue
qui n'est pas la nôtre
alors que vous savez le russe qui est
compliqué c'est les 25 premières années
après c'est facile
justement non justement les russes le
russe j'avais beaucoup de cours de russe
au début j'avais six heures de russes
par jour et après j'ai eu quatre heures
de route par jour et puis les russes
étaient été bon correctement il m'a dit
beaucoup de pêcheurs c'est bien ça tant
que tu parles pas bien le russe et bien
on va donner du russe tout le temps dans
ces îles vous responsabilise c'était à
moi de m'investir pour apprendre le
russe parce que tant que je connaissais
pas le russe est bien j'allais en faire
de plus en plus les comme le russe n'est
pas un russe technique qu'on apprenait
qu'un professeur mais du russe
littéraire qui était assez compliqué oui
pouchkine lire la pravda en face à des
choses vraiment un peu dur quand même
donc je me suis dépêché d'apprendre le
russe correctement parce que j'ai
compris que les russes n'allais pas me
laisser le choix dans ce domaine là et
oui parce que si jamais vous comprenez
pas ce qu'on est en train de vous dire
dans une situation un peu extrême
c'est un vrai problème c'est ceci dit le
russe que nous parlons nous et des
russes techniques et les chiffres les
ordinateurs les systèmes sont des
des mots qui ont souvent des origines
latines donc on comprenait je n'étais
pas extrêmement fort en ruse mais
j'arrive à comprendre tout ce qui se
passait mais la veille du décollage vous
raconter qu'on vous projette un film
toujours le même on va voir la fiche
tout de suite ce film s'intitule en
français le soleil blanc du désert et
vous dit prêt à voir chaque décollage à
baïkonour
on projette ce film là pourquoi selon
lui à parce que le camp quand vous
faites un décollage
on doit s'entourer de tout le tout et
traditions qui ont qui ont été faites
pour les premiers vols
les premiers vols on voyait ce film là
peut-être pas le premier 1er mai dans
les premiers vols on l'a vu ce film là
est toute la tradition qui entoure les
premiers vols de l'espace chez
soviétique et je les russes
eh bien on le respecte jusqu'à
aujourd'hui un petit peu comme si ç'a
porté chance donc on respecte et ça ça
vous donne un référentiel qui est très
important pour aussi pour vous rassurer
parce que c'est un c'est un rempart qui
nous rassure juste avant le décollage
puisque quand même c'est un moment quand
même un peu inquiétant et d'avoir ces
choses systématique que vous vivez
lorsque vous êtes doublure lorsque vous
êtes accompagnons et lorsque vous n'êtes
ni roi et bien c'est quelque chose qui
rassure avant le décollage
mais celle qui raconte ce film j'imagine
qu'il n'a pas été choisi au hasard ils
vous racontent alors c'est quelque chose
c'était un film symbolique parce que
c'était le premier western faible par
les soviétiques à l'époque c'est un film
qui est basée sur beaucoup d'humour et
beaucoup de jeux de mots en russe c'est
pour ça que nous étrangers on avait du
mal à le comprendre
moi j'ai dû le voir fois et je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses et beaucoup
de situations qui était un petit peu
marrante rigolotes ou mais c'était quand
même donc aujourd'hui encore on passe
aux primes là et ce film est tellement
important qu'il y à un restaurant moscou
qui s'appelle biéler son époux style
c'était en plein centre de moscou
et ils ont fait le décor du film dans
son restaurant pour vous dire que ce je
m'étais vraiment quelque chose de très
important pour les soviétiques alors là
on a la fiche russe mais le film et
existe en français en on peut le voir je
ne les ai pas vus aimez vous me donnez
envie de le voir
vous êtes partis sur la mission soyouz
thème case c'était la case iem
expédition vers la station mir vous êtes
parti de 27 juillet 1992 avec deux
russes le décollage justement c'est
c'est quand même quelque chose de
particulièrement éprouvant on en a une
espèce de deux d'expérience nous les
terriens part par l'intermédiaire des
films américains
est-ce que ça ressemble à ce qu'on nous
montre à ce moment-là et et est-ce que
c'est décrit petit bleu alors c'est
c'est un moment assez particulier parce
que ce qu'on voit dans les films se
rapproche un peu de la réalité quand
même sauf que vous quand vous êtes dans
la dans le vaisseau soyouz au décollage
vous avez en plus les vibrations et
après décollage vous avez quand même
l'accélération au décollage on va
prendre progressivement 4g donc vous
allez faire quatre fois votre poids si
vous êtes 80km 320 kg qui vont s'écraser
sur votre vente et vous allez garder ses
quatre j'ai pratiquement tout le temps
jusqu'à la fin du décollage qu'il a duré
9 minutes
alors quand on est pilote de chasse on
va prendre peut-être 10 g sur 20
secondes
là on va prendre pendant un peu moins de
gérer pendant neuf que le dos au départ
c'est amusant après ça va bien et au
bout de 9 minutes quand ça se termine on
est content vraiment d'arriver en haut
mais ce qui est surprenant c'est la
rapidité du décollage à dirk kuyt entre
eux altitude 08 09 minutes après vous
êtes dans l'espace et vous tournez à 28
milles kilomètres à l'heure une vitesse
qui est absolument ahurissante
c'est extrêmement rapide on n'a aucune
sensation cette vitesse on le veut on la
parle à vue de la terre ouvriers la
terre et vous vous voyez que ça va très
très vite quand vous prenez une photo
d'un objet sur l'accord si loulou que la
photo vous vous retrouvez dans le pays
d'à côté très rapidement donc il faut il
faudra très attention à anticiper vous
allez quand même trente fois plus vite
qu'un adjoint de digne grosso modo en 92
on est six ans après l'accident fin
l'explosion même delà de la navette
challenger avec cette jeune institutrice
qui étaient à bord ce avait complètement
traumatisé l'amérique
il y avait tous ces enfants qui voyait
pour la première fois à partir avec des
avec des astronautes
à civile une civile en l'occurrence une
institutrice en plus elle a explosé au
bout de quelques secondes on peut pas ne
pas l'avoir oublié en 92 canton quand on
décolle à son tour c'est vrai que c'est
un accident dramatique pour les usa
dramatique pour la communauté des
astronautes et moi j'ai commencé
vraiment mon travail des astronautes
après ma sélection de 85 par l'accident
que challenger donc à ce moment là je
les gens me disaient moi tu vas arrêter
parce que c'est trop dangereux c'est pas
la peine de coach continue et moi
j'étais motivé pour le faire et je
savais que je prenais des risques autant
quand vous êtes club de chasse aux
pilotes d'essai vous prenez aussi des
risques mais j'avais accepté de prendre
des risques même des risques extrêmes
pour vivre cette mission ils ont tout
pour bâtir un petit peu le futur de
l'espace donc il ya aussi une différence
est importante entre la navette
américaine et le vaisseau soyouz
c'est que le vaisseau soyouz à une tour
d'éjection c'est à dire que si au
décollage aux avait un problème
cette tour va extraire la capsule soyouz
voit la montée à 10 km pour la faire
poser en parachute loin de l'explosion
de la boule de feu et ça fonctionne et
trois fois dans l'histoire et ça
fonctionne de façon très efficace non
simulés aujourd'hui de décoller sur une
capsule est quand même beaucoup plus
rassurant côté collées sur les spatiale
même si la navette et d'engins
extrêmement sophistiqué et d'ailleurs
même les américains dans leur navette
actuelle dans leur station actuelle ce p
6 par exemple ils ont aussi une tour
d'éjection beau souvent les équipages en
cas de problème dans votre stuff et le
livre et le film qui en a arrêté tiré
on voyait bien les premiers astronautes
américains qui étaient tous comme vous
des pilotes de chasse et des pilotes
d'essai au départ leur frustration à ne
pas piloter justement parce qu'au fond
ils se retrouvaient les premiers dans
des capsules c'est à peine si on leur
avait fait un hublot et in piloter pas
est ce que vous avez est ce que vous
avez ressenti la même frustration au
départ le projet harmos est un projet
d'avion spatial mais hélas vous vous
retrouvez passagers oui alors
effectivement vous avez ou si vous
pensez juste en termes de pilotage pur
et si si votre but c'est de faire du
pilotage
vous pourriez sentir une frustration
mais elle laisse lorsque vous donnez
dans l'espace
si vous voulez les expériences que vous
allez faire d'être dans la station
spatiale d'être le temps au beso les
tâches de rendez vous entre le vaisseau
la station spatiale qui se fondent
automatique et en back up manuel si
elles sont tellement intéressante que la
frustration disparaît tout de suite moi
je n'ai aucun sentiment de frustration
après mon volant soyouz
alors que mon adn à moi c'est bon d'être
pilote alors justement le soyouz va à 28
milles kilomètres heure la station mir
elle est en orbite à 300-400 km de
l'alter elles aussi veulent 28 mille
kilomètres heure comment se fait
l'arrimage parce que l' image il est
très précis vous avez deux vaisseaux qui
vont à 28 milles kilomètres heure à peu
près et qui doivent à un moment entrer
l'un en l'autre
oui alors vous avez des radars qui
permette êtes deux systèmes radar de
systèmes de navigation qui leur est de
faire le rendez-vous du vaisseau vers la
station et cette loi de navigation va
permettre aux vaisseaux de se rapprocher
tout doucement de la station par une
différence d'altitude
comme on est plus bas que la station on
va plus de cauna station et on va se
rapprocher par derrière tout en
remontant latitude et à la faim dans les
derniers kilomètres c'est un
rapprochement en ligne droite
et lorsque vous êtes vraiment très très
proches c'est un pcet un pilotage
toujours fait par les ordinateurs de
bord pour que le co ne le cône de la
station puissent recevoir le mât
d'arrimage du vaisseau spatial en ça se
fait de façon automatique et c'est
extrêmement précis rappelez-vous nous
sommes la station à 28 kilomètres à
l'heure le vaisseau tu avais tu mets de
metalor mais il faut entrer dedans avec
une vitesse de 30 cm par seconde
pas trop vite tout cas vous casser le
maximum et pas trop lentement sinon ça
va pas se bloquer au bout du compte il
n'y aura pas deux il y aura pas de
rendez vous donc cette manoeuvre
extrêmement précises qui est fait par
des ordinateurs mais le cosmonaute qui
est au milieu du vaisseau peut également
faire le pilotage manuel
un petit peu comme sur un avion vous
entrez ensuite dans la station mir et là
on vous propose un café 1
c'est d'où le titre de votre livre un
café dans l'espace alors c'est plus
encore plus cocasse que ça c'est à dire
que quand vous faites le rendez vous il
ya des périodes vous êtes loin de la
station où nous rapprocher pour vous
arrêter vous rapprochez vous arrêtez
tout allait bien et dans une période où
il y avait un silence radio
les cosmonautes qui était dans la
station me disent alors que moi j'étais
encore dans le vaisseau pas encore
arrivé j'étais encore 20 km 10
vous allez arriver tout heures dans la
station michel est ce qu'on te prépares
un thé un café ou un chocolat mais je
trouvais ça tellement touchant que vous
êtes à 28 la leur dans une petite boîte
vous être crevé après deux jours de
voyage on n'a pratiquement pas dormi et
les russes avec l'ours hospitalité
extrêmement importante
me disent michele qui préfèrent un café
avec succès la la simplicité de la
proposition
comparé à la complexité de notre
position par rapport à la station ont
fait un décalage qui meuf qui m'a frappé
qui m'a marqué mais en quoi est ce que
vous êtes différent michel tonini de la
plupart des gens qui ne sont jamais
allés dans l'espace je me sens à l'aise
que ça a bouleversé chez vous alors que
ce que ça donne à votre question et à
206 la question d'abord avant pourquoi
j'ai fait ce vol dans l'espace et parce
que je me suis proposé comme volontaire
pour inscrire dans la sélection des
astronautes étaient parce que j'ai tenu
la sélection des astronautes grâce avec
un peu de chance la motivation et
surtout renvoyé une très forte
motivation quand même et puis un
acharnement sur la sélection et ce qui a
modifié un petit peu mon regard par
rapport à l'ensemble de ce que j'ai vécu
avant le volet après le rhum c'est que
lorsque vous lorsque vous êtes terrien
comme j'étais avant
vous avez une vision du globe qui est un
petit peu spécial avec des des souvenirs
de la géographie ouvriers les
territoires les terrains fallait
territoire les pays avec des frontières
qui sont des frontières horizontale ou
cadets des gros traits noirs entre les
pays lorsque vous décollez dans l'espace
ses frontières disparaissent et s'éteint
c'est un flot continu d'un bout à
l'autre y'a pas de trait entre les
séparations des pays par contre il y a
un trait qui le trait entre la terre
et l'atmosphère et se serait fait 100 km
c'est le très noir 100 km d'atmosphère
et nous on a 400 km au dessus donc ça
veut dire que il ya vraiment une
sensation de fragilité de la vie sur la
terre qui est née cette atmosphère et on
se rend compte que cette atmosphère que
nous avons sur la terre c'est un petit
peu de scaphandres que nous avons quand
on est cosmonaute et si jamais cette
atmosphère disparaît pour une raison ou
pour une autre
on est tous morts donc on se rend compte
beaucoup plus que les autres de cette
fragilité de la terre et on se rend
compte du fait que nous devons nous unir
pour tous ensemble protéger la terre est
ce que là la pesanteur est ce que cette
agréable c'est très agréable ce quelque
chose c'est même une addiction parce que
au début vous êtes un peu malade
appelez nous ont parlé mais tabouret
tournant donc en apesanteur ça reprend
un peu le tabouret tournant mais en
moins fort bien sûr parce que on peut le
stopper
bougeant - la tête en bougeant - le
corps n'a rien le mal de l'espace est
aussi au bout de quelques jours bien
vous êtes vous est adapté à l'apesanteur
et c'est un sentiment agréable par
exemple je prends mon crayon je la mets
devant moi et bien il va tenir devant
moi et ça me paraît naturel et ça me
paraît inconcevable qu'il puisse en être
autrement serre que dans notre cerveau
vous êtes en apesanteur et c'est normal
et on s'habitue par exemple si je veux
aller d'un point à un autre et bien je
veux faire une galipette dans un sens
pour passer au dessus du groupe de
personnes qui travaillent donc wait
on se bouscule pas c'est quelque chose
qu'on apprend rapidement et qui est
vraiment extrêmement agréable et est-ce
qu'on revient à la pesanteur facilement
c'est ce que ça n'est pas comme eux de
conduire à gauche quand on va en
angleterre on s'y fait très bien et puis
quand on vient en france on continue de
conduire à gauche alors c'est oui c'est
un peu c'est un peu comme c'est à dire
que quand vous arrivez dans l'espace le
plus dur c'est le mal de l'espace sans
que le mâle décibulles air qui permet
enfin kid qui rend certains accros à ces
malades et mais comment rentrer au sol
c'est aussi un peu levé stimulant mais
c'est surtout la lourdeur parce que
quand vous êtes comme votre poids était
zéro pendant 15 jours ou même pas tenant
l'épaule et pour six mois
quand vous que votre poids et et 0 quand
vous revenez sur le sol tout est lourd
bujumbura est lourd votre tête est lourd
ou penché la tête sur le côté les
muscles du cou se sont affaiblies
complètement et il faut vraiment tenir
la tête tout est vraiment très très
lourd et tout ce que vous prenez
dans les mains ton parterre très
facilement et vous casser beaucoup de
choses dans les premiers jours après
l'atterrissage et la notion de temps
bouleversée
heureusement elle est bouleversée mais
ce qu'on fait c'est que on l'a au cadre
on se met par exemple avec un calage du
centre de l'eure de centre de moscou par
exemple quand il est 7 heures du matin
au centre de contrôle de moscou
eh bien il est 7 heures du matin dans la
station taureau mais attends
artificielle à 7 heures du matin on
ouvre les hublots on allume la lumière
et le sort à 11 heures heure de moscou
on ferme les hublots confirme la lumière
et en droit et pourtant au même moment
vous fait le tour de la terre à toute
vitesse
oui mais on a choisi de ne pas se
coucher toutes les 45 minutes parce que
ce sera quand même très très long et du
temps perdu de refaire son lit de se
brosser les dents ce soit par jour donc
au hong kong garde le rythme terriens
qui est de 24 heures et on se cale au
rythme therrien est aujourd'hui dans la
station spatiale
on a pris une heure ce qui est leur gmt
le méridien de greenwich pour que ça
accord des russes et enrique mais
justement alors moi ce qui me fascine
c'est cette vitesse à laquelle vous
tourner autour de la terre que moi comme
tous les voyageurs j'ai fait mes calculs
et je suis tombé sur le fait que en 30
heures on peut être n'importe où sur le
globe
en trente heures aujourd'hui ça paraît
très court mais mais vous vous avez fait
le tour de la terre plusieurs fois en 45
minutes
et forcément ça aussi ça change quelque
chose dans la perception
on a alloué par seulement deux sauts
gannett mais de la géographie en général
ça vous va devoir d'un mouvement de
loisirs le soir après dix heures de soin
aux huit ans le soir quand vous avez
fini vos expériences et bien vous allez
choix de regarder un film ou bien dans
les périodes de jour qui dure 45 minutes
de regarder la terre et de voir des
choses que vous n'aurez jamais le temps
de voir toute votre vie parce que je
comptais on est entre 51 degrés nord et
sud donc balayé par des signaux et toute
la terre en permanence
et donc on arrive à avoir des choses qui
sont qu'ils sont invisibles à l'oeil nu
de votre vivant parce qu'il faudrait
prendre l'avion pendant des années des
années pour arriver à voir ce même
spectacle
on dit qu'on ne voit strictement rien
qui étaient fabriqués de la main de
l'homme même pas la muraille de chine
depuis l'espace vous le confirmer non on
alors moi j'ai pas vu le mari dessus
parce que je suis passé sur la chine de
nuit par contre les pyramides on les
voir les pyramides academy les remettre
voit les pyramides donc voit les
pyramides on va les routes on voit les
autres ou tomber les villes et tous été
construits par les êtres humains donc on
voit on voit la construction humaine on
voit peut-être pas les avions parce
qu'ils sont un peu petit mais les
bateaux les routes à rouen les voir
aller traîner pour le titre et noir voit
beaucoup de choses comme c'est
absolument incroyable
j'ai souvent pensé à depuis de
l'écrivain hugo vide à ceux qui sont
dans l'espace depuis que nous on vit de
la façon dont on vit aujourd'hui jeudi
doivent se trouver très très à l'abri
est ce que est ce qu'on peut se sentir à
l'abri quand on est là haut
effectivement il ya environ un mois j'ai
une conférence zoom avec les gens qui
sont dans la station spatiale et c'est
un japonais qui a organisé ça et d ici
on n'est qu'au bout de free ça veut dire
que l'on peut s'embrasser ont dû vous
êtes touchés il n'y a vraiment aucun
microbe on est vérifiée avant on est
vérifiée complètement avance qu'elle est
pourtant rêve la boue comme tout le
monde est vérifiée il n'y a pas de co
vite donc on est vraiment tranquille et
on a on a un petit point commun des
astronautes a c'est qu'on est confiné
comme peu sauf qu'on n'a pas la belle
vue de la terre ont fait une pause
michel on se retrouve juste après
d'accord
[Musique]
nous est de retour avec l'astronaute
français michel tonini qui publie un
café dans l'espace aux éditions humaines
sciences on vient de parler de votre
premier vol avec avec les russes 7 ans
plus tard vous allez repartir sur la
navette columbia cette fois ce sera le
23 juillet 1999 avec des américains avec
des femmes je crois que c'est le premier
vol d'ailleurs commandé par une femme
auquel vous avez la chance de participer
alors qu'est ce que ça change quand il
ya des femmes dans l'espace avec vous
alors ça change beaucoup de choses
surtout que nous avons eu un vol avec
des panacées importante on a une panne
moteur au décollage et une panne
électrique totale au décollage et
lorsque vous avez des situations de
stress assez importante le couple
homme-femme est le mieux adapté pour
répondre efficacement à des à des
tensions importantes dans les
réparations et dans l'ail dans les
gestions de crise ans je suis rendu
compte que hommes et femmes se complète
vraiment très très bien dans cette
période qui sont aux noms stressait
l'écusson de votre mission va le voir
vous raconter dans votre livre que vous
avez dû insister pour que des figures le
le drapeau français
ce qu'était ben gagner alors c'était pas
gagné parce que je me suis rendu compte
que si je voulais que le drapeau
français à soi dans le logo il faudrait
que je fasse l'écusson m'a même donc je
me fut je me suis porté volontaire pour
faire les cuissons et à la fin les
américains m'ont dit oui mais c'est pas
bien parce que si tu me laisses cuzon
français il faut qu'il soit en bas de
l'écusson américain à droite et plus
petit donc je dis ok on va faire tout ça
et on a mené tout jamais tout sachez le
le dessinateur qui a mis tous en marche
et donc on est sorti avec un des repos
français qui était petit et trop comme
breaking était plus grand et lorsqu'il a
fallu faire le vrai qu sont brodés la
couturière a dit moi je sais pas faire
d'imputer drapeau aussi petit os qui
poudroie prod soit de la même taille et
l'équipage du gourma sida quand on va
rester comme ça donc j'ai j'ai peint peu
du forcing mais au moins je suis fier
d'avoir mon propre aux français qui a
décollé
dans la station va dans la navette
américaine avec nous quelle différence y
at-il entre les les russes et les
américains dans l'espace avant dans
votre livre justement par rapport à ces
pannes dont vous parlez vous dites qu'au
fond les russes les russes étaient
beaucoup plus familier des pannes ça les
dérangeait pas qui est dépanné ça
dérange les dérangeait pas de dettes de
voir les réparer les américains beaucoup
plus alors le système est différent sûr
que quand vous décoller avec un vaisseau
russe vous êtes dans une station
spatiale et la station ne redescend pas
de tous les trois mois pour être réparé
donc il faut qu'on répare là haut ça que
le cosmonaute russe qui veut dans
l'espace doit être un bon réparateur et
surtout il doit voir ce désir de 2,2 de
savoir mettre les mains dans le cambouis
s'il faut le faire chez les américains
c'est différent parce que quand vous
décoller vous devez être capable de
réparer certaines choses mais en général
la navette se pose à votre quinze jours
et au bout de 15 jours
les pannes qui seront importantes seront
réparés pour le prochain vol c'est un
concept qu'un petit peu différent en
particulier des scaphandres les
scaphandres sent toujours utilisé les
mêmes scaphandre quand vous êtes dans la
station russe alors que l'esc
affronteront à ramener le sol après
chaque match et américains du temps de
l'époque de la navette et donc on
pouvait les ajuster les réadapter le
sable qui vend nos différents c'est pour
ça que les réparations n'ont pas le même
signification 1 chez les russes chez les
amériques on a cette impression alors là
aussi probablement véhiculée par le
cinéma et notamment le cinéma américain
que les russes sont plus dans la
débrouille
ils ont moins d'argent ils sont donc il
répare plus pour cette raison là en tout
cas en l'imaginent
ils sont plus dans la débrouille à un
moment donné un coup de pied dedans et
puis ça remarche par miracle mais là
encore c'est une vision américaine
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous alors
on pourrait oui on pourrait on pourrait
dire que les russes sont plus un système
débrouille mais finalement encore une
fois comme ils doivent rester longtemps
et la station qui doit être qui doit
fonctionner pendant des années des
années ont de pouvoir savoir réparer
régulièrement là haut et pour qu'on
puisse réparer
il faut que le système soit simple alors
surtout quand je dis ça mais il faut
qu'il soit réparé a par exemple les
toilettes du temps des navettes des
toilettes sur les américains n'étaient
pas réparable dans l'instant la navette
par contre les russes ils doivent être
réparable
parce que si vous n'êtes pas te répondre
aux six mois cette d'un catastrophique
sur un vol de 15 jours ça peut
éventuellement se gérer mais pas sur un
vol de longue durée
vous avez volé cinq jours sur sur
columbia et quand vous êtes très
descendus au sol vous êtes aperçu qu'il
y avait trois trous dans la cuillère du
moteur droit
on est quand même quatre ans avant
l'explosion de la navette columbia parce
qu'elle va exploser elle aussi est ce
que vous avez eu peur rétrospectivement
alors on n'a pas peur parce que quand
vous êtes dans la mission d'abord vous
avez confiance dans les ingénieurs que
vous les connaissez bien dans les landes
qui ont préparé la navette avait
confiance dans votre équipage parce que
vous avez été entraîné avec eux pendant
deux ans vous êtes confiant selon le
centre de contrôle et donc franchement
j'ai pas eu peur mais j'ai compris après
coup après le vol j'ai compris que quand
on était passé quand même très très
proche de la catastrophe parce que on a
perdu un petit mot un petit morceau de
moteur qui faisait dix centimètres qui a
tapé sur la cuillère du moteur droit et
donc comme ses cuirs sont enroulés de
tubes qui contiennent de l'hydrogène
primaire on a perdu de l'hydrogène et ce
moteur a brûlé un petit peu on est monté
à 70% de la valeur limite de la
température de la cuillère et on a su
après après la très sage que un
ingénieur qui était à houston avec
compris y avait un problème avait vu que
le moteur était chaud et étaient prêts à
nous faire couper le moteur ce qui
aurait était complexe parce qu'on a
décollé de nuit on a décollé on était
extrêmement lourd on avait la charge
utile la plus longue jamais lancé par la
nasa et on était centré arrière ou pc
les conditions les pires pour se reposer
il y aura plus qu on fasse en cas de
panne moteur de coupures moteur qu'on
fasse un rtls dire ou partez vers l'est
ou fait demi tour et vous venez vous
reposer sur cap canaveral
si madame qui n'a jamais été faite ce
nouveau simulateur donc c'est quand même
un peu complexe michel tonini est ce que
vous y croyez vous veulent habiter
wehrmacht
alors oui bien sûr on va faire des vols
vers mars pas tout de suite parce qu'il
ya encore pas mal de choses à régler
tout d'abord la motorisation qui n'est
pas encore à mon point
passez sur une motorisation à plasma
roux ionique de façon aller plus vite
sur mars
faire des voyages en trois mois au lieu
de six mois et surtout se protéger des
radiations parce que vous savez que
entre entre la terre et mars il ya un
temps de voyage qui dure six mois et on
va faire ce voyage le moment où lé
l'activité solaire sur un minimum de
façon à donner le moins de radiations
qui iront vers les corps humain qui
iront faire le voyage par contre ce
qu'on sait pas prêt vous prédire ce sont
les éruptions solaires des camps il ya
une éruption solaire
il ya quand même beaucoup de protons et
beaucoup de particules qui porte du
soleil qui viennent dans la dans
l'habitacle et qui font beaucoup de
dégâts
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas encore bien
se protéger de ces éruptions solaires et
donc on va y arriver bien sûr ça à
prendre plusieurs années
peut-être plusieurs dizaines d'années
avant qu'on arrive à se protéger et pas
ce moment là on pourra faire le voyage
vers mars
mais il ya alors vous l'avais dit il ya
le problème de de la longueur du voyage
six mois pour l'instant en plus il faut
une fenêtre où la distance entre la
terre et mars est la plus courte pour
que ça fait six mois justement mais
ensuite il faut attendre une nouvelle
fenêtre pour pouvoir revenir
donc on sait qu'un voyage sur mars ce
serait a dit et ce serait au moins trois
ans
de temps avant de pouvoir revenir sur
terre donc il faut arriver sur mars
vous l'avez décrit tout à l'heure quand
auront la pesanteur fait qu'on ne peut
plus rien tenir et mais au moment où ça
nous ça vous est arrivé vous reveniez
sur ses terres vous a accueilli mais là
à ceux qui partiront sur ma ça leur
arrivera au moment où ils arriveront sur
mars c'est à dire au moment où il y aura
personne pour les accueillir et où ils
auront intérêt en plus à être en forme
parce qu'il faudra construire au moins
une base en tout cas être capable de
faire quelque chose de ses dix doigts
or c'est le moment même où ils en seront
incapables vous y croyez moi même oui
parce que premièrement la gravité sur
mars est plus faible que la gravité sur
terre donc on se ment serait quand même
plus j'ai sur mars
deuxièmement votre corps se réadapte ça
va prendre quelques jours 10 en une
semaine peut-être dix jours pour
s'adapter et après on se réadapte comme
son père et la durée du vol sera
suffisamment longue pour que l'on puisse
anticiper ce temps de réadaptation
alors quand vous parlez du vol qui va
durer deux ans trois ans savait une
combustion chimiques mais si vous partez
sur une compétition eunic à plasma avec
deux moteurs du type d'asie mir qui
existe déjà à la nasa enfin vous pouvez
le faire un voyage juste avant la
distance minimale entre entre la terre
et mars
là ça dure trois mois vous restez trois
mâles sur mars et vous rentrez à la
distance encore un petit peu après deux
des dix ans minimale ces deux ou trois
mois que vous arrivez à faire le total
en neuf mois et ça ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher en radiation et surtout en
support logistique que vous aurez sur
place par contre le moteur à plasma n'a
pas encore volé dans l'espace donc il
faut qu'on il faut qu'on le fasse voler
avant d'arriver à à faire ses missions
assez importante sur mars et est le fait
de vous avez vu toujours vous en partant
sur lèze à la fois sur la navette et sur
la station spatiale
vous avez toujours vu la terre et quand
on va sur la lune on continue de voir la
terre l'idée de ne plus voir la terre
que la terre disparaît ce qui arriva à
ceux qui partiront pour pour marc c'est
quelque chose qui paraît personne n'a
jamais vécu ça aucun être humain n'a
jamais vécu la disparition de deux de la
terre
c'est pas ce qui peut se passer voilà
c'est vrai que sur le plan psychologique
c'est bien c'est difficile sur le plan
psychologique mais c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis au point en 2000 2003 un
entraînement un entraînement hdp 1 pour
un autre nom psychologique pour que l'on
puisse s'affranchir de ses références et
on puisse sortir de sa zone de confort
notamment on en ne ramenant que nous
faisons en europe en sardet où on se met
dans des cages pendant quinze jours mais
on pourrait très bien envisager de faire
ce travail en cave pendant plusieurs
mois pour isoler la personne de la
vision de la terre de la vision d'un
autre âge parce que quand vous êtes dans
une cave
vous êtes complètement isolé mois on a
aujourd'hui un bon un bon panel
d'entraînement sur différents systèmes
en montagne sous l'eau sous terre dans
les régions froides on survit pour
durcir un petit peu les astronautes aux
conditions qu'il aura quand ils
arrivèrent massant la vision d'un ter
sans révision d'aline ça c'est la
première chose
deuxième chose vous savez que dans le
futur vaisseau ça sera un petit peu
comme dans les futurs avions
on n'aura pas des hublots comme
aujourd'hui avec une vision sur la terre
ça sera des petites caméras lcd avec une
qualité extraordinaire et vous verrez la
terre beaucoup mieux que si vous la
voyez par des caméras qui vous
représenteront ce que vous aurez à voir
et on peut très bien envisager d'avoir
la même chose lorsque nous irons sandras
avec un système de caméra qui vous
montre le total de vos extérieurs
donc on peut on peut tricher d'une façon
ou d'une autre est aussi sûr entraîné
les astronautes
vous vous y croyez quand vous voyez des
films tuerait même pas jusqu'à la guerre
des étoiles mais pourquoi pas vous citer
la guerre des étoiles dans dans votre
livre qu'à un moment on puisse être
aussi à l'aise
nous les êtres humains dans l'espace
alors aidé par des robots ou pas mais
être aussi à l'aise dans l'espace qu'ils
le sont dans ses films c'est à dire
avoir une gravité dans les vaisseaux
pour marcher normalement comme une
marche sur le pont d'un bateau ou dans
un 747 et se poser sur d'autres planètes
que celle que que nous connaissons
jusqu'à présent alors le fait d'avoir
une gravité artificielle elle n'est pas
encore vraiment les airs moi je suis pas
tellement pour parce que cette gravité
et elle est nécessaire pour refaire de
l'osce
pour garder de l'os et garder des
muscles dans les gens parce que quand
vous êtes dans l'espace et bien vous
flottez vos gens vont s'affaiblir notre
corps va s'affaiblir musculairement et
au niveau du calcium donc on a réussi à
compenser cela aide le sport on fait
aujourd'hui deux heures et demie deux
originaux sport par jour pour garder du
muscle et garder de l'os mais il faut
savoir que le sport en plus de tout ça
nous donne un support psychologique
parce que quelqu'un qui fait du sport
régulièrement deux heures de sport par
jour pendant six mois mais il y là il
suffit d'une résistance suffisante pour
lutter contre tous les petits moments de
spleen qui pourraient avoir le sport est
un garant de votre forme positive
psychologique vous croyez au tourisme
spatial je parle du vrai tourisme pas là
pour l'instant il ya une dizaine
douzaine peut-être de deux touristes qui
ont payé plusieurs dizaines de millions
de dollars pour aller dans l'espace mais
à un tourisme grand public
vous pensez que c'est possible alors ça
ça va être posée pas tout de suite parce
que les prix sont encore élevés mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on refait un petit
peu on revit un peu ce qu'on a vécu de
l'aviation rappelez-vous de l'aviation
départ c'était vraiment des vols était
juste réservé à des initiés puis après
pour des moyens militaires et après
c'était les vols commerciaux bien nous
aurons la même chose pour les vols
spatiaux
au début ce sont les vols des pionniers
que nous sommes puis après ça sera
possible et accessible à beaucoup de
personnes bien sûr avec des prix qui
sont qui seront intéressants
quand je prends en exemple le voyage de
virgin galactic inquiète un voyage qui
est quand même en dessous du million
parce que c'est à 200000 euros donc on
peut faire un voyage à la limite de
l'atmosphère à 100 km et revenir sur
terre avec environ un vol d'une heure et
demi d'eau quatre minutes d'apesanteur
oui on arrive tout doucement à avoir des
bugs qui sont quand même techniquement
et financièrement réalisable en 92 quand
vous partez pour la première fois c'est
françois mitterrand qui est président de
la république en 99 quand vous partez
pour la seconde fois c'est jacques
chirac
vous dites dans votre livre que françois
mitterrand a été le dernier président
français à s'intéresser à l'espace ça
veut dire que donc jacques chirac ne s'y
intéressait déjà plus depuis j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit revenu
vous le regrettez et comment l'expliquez
vous d'ailleurs pourquoi est-ce que
aussi bien à charles de gaulle valéry
giscard d'estaing françois mitterrand
à chaque fois on était là pour quand il
s'est agi que la france devienne d'une
manière ou d'une autre une puissance
spatiale et pourquoi ça nous intéresse
moins depuis alors cessé c'est un c'est
quelque chose que je constate et que je
constate
et c'est une différence d'ailleurs par
rapport aux autres pays quand je vois
par exemple en russie
les présidents russes s'intéressent
beaucoup l'espace mais ces présidents
américains s'intéressent toujours un peu
l'espace en allemagne j'ai connu angela
merkel qui s'intéressait beaucoup à
l'espace mais en france les les hommes
politiques ne s'intéressent pas trop
l'espace est juste c'est dommage parce
que finalement l'espace et une vision à
long terme et donc on a l'impression que
l'homme politique s'intéresse à une
vision à court terme en occultant la
vision à long terme qui essaient de
l'espace et en plus l'espace donne une
forme de rêve une forme de deux choses
positives dans notre univers savoir que
nous avons par exemple nous en france
nous avons des français qui vont dans
l'espace comme thomas pesquet c'est
quelque chose de rassurant qui peut
aider les jeunes à étudier et je suis
vraiment persuadé que les études sont
vraiment le garant de la sécurité d'un
pays et de l'intégrité d'un pays
justement thomas pesquet il a ravivé
beaucoup l'intérêt que le grand public
pouvait avoir pour l'espace vous étiez
chef du centre des astronautes européens
quand il a été recruté
c'est vous qui l'avez recruter thomas le
pesqué comment recrute un astronaute
quelle qualité
cherche-t-on la résistance physique
j'imagine bien mais quoi d'autre
alors moi j'ai fait un recrutement
différent parce que nous avons fait le
recrutement en 2007 2008
moi j'ai été j'ai quitté la nasa en 2003
pour arriver à cologne au son des
entraînements principalement pour
m'occuper de cette sélection donc j'ai
eu quand même le temps de réfléchir delà
de la préparer et de la finance et
quentin faut quand même un certain paix
parce qu'il voulait faire sur l'ensemble
des pays européens
et moi je me suis attaché à avoir des
qualités pour les astronautes qui est
des qualités nouvelles qui étaient plus
basé sur la psychologie donc je suis
basé sur des gens qui étaient bien
alignés
par exemple étaient alignés qu'avait
l'humilité qui n'était ni agressif ni
passif et surtout qu'ils étaient très
motivés donc c'était un petit peu les
caractéristiques que j'avais vu qui
manquaient lors des vols précédents et
les six que j'ai recruté dont thomas
pesquet ont tous ses qualités qui était
nécessaire pour faire des vols longue
durée et les six ont très bien réussi
les vols aussi bien que thomas pesquet
vous l'avez dit c'est pourquoi la
psychologie c'est parce que les vols
sont de plus en plus longs au fond c'est
parce que les vols sont plus longs et
puis on le voit très bien vous avez vu
comment nous sommes quand on est confiné
on commence à vraiment avoir des
problèmes psychologiques qui peuvent
survenir
c'est dur à vivre le confinement et bien
imaginez vous dans l'espace c'est encore
plus dur même si vous avez la vue de la
terre est extrêmement belle d'être
enfermé sans avoir un moyen de sortir
parce que l'attestation de cirque ne
sert pas dans l'espace ça il faut vous
êtes enfermé vraiment pendant six mois
eh bien il faut avoir des qualités
psychologiques spéciale pour pouvoir
soutenir ce genre de ce genre de vols
longs mais justement on n'a pas eu
connaissance en tout cas de de crise
extrêmement grave dans ces huit clos que
sont les vols spatiaux ce sont des huis
clos et pourtant on n'a jamais eu un
qu'il n'y a pas eu de bagarre en tout
cas on ne le sait pas il ya eu d'aidé je
me souviens de deux russes qui ne
s'adressaient plus la parole pendant de
longues semaines voire de longs mois
mais ils n'en sont pas venus aux mains
alors cela dit droit n'est pas facile de
se battre dans l'espace alors il ya eu
quand même des conflits dans les vols
longs chez les russes ou même chez les
américains mais il ya surtout eu les
problèmes qu'avaient fait les russes
était écrit dans des livres en
cyrillique donc que c'était pas trop
traduit un jeu on n'en parlait pas trop
à l'occident par contre lorsqu'il ya eu
vous savez les vols shottle mire donc la
navette spatiale américaine a laissé
arrimé sur la station mir et chaque fois
on passe et un astronaute américain de
la navette américaine vers la station
mir et la danse et sur cette plante qui
a duré cinq ans il ya eu six ou sept
vols d'américains et là on a eu les pas
des plus graves jamais eu on a eu le feu
à bord onu la collision qui a entraîné
une dépressurisation de cesser les
choses les plus graves
et là on s'est rendu compte que nos
astronautes ont pas forcément bien réagi
donc on s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait
premièrement qu on les sélectionne
différemment avec des qualités
psychologiques différent de scotch aux
composés aux prélats et surtout qu on
les entraîne pour les pour les sortir de
la zone de confort pour qu'il soit plus
résistant sur ses vols de longue durée
c'est ce qu'ont ces ateliers à faire en
2003 avec ses entraînements que nous
faisons du multi couche sur dix
entraînements en montagne sous terre
sous mer ou dans les régions froides où
on survit c'est dans votre livre vous
parlez des tests de quotient
intellectuel qu'on vous fait faire ça à
l'air d'être particulièrement important
il faut savoir s'adapter à des
situations nouvelles en fait c'est ça
qu'on demande et c'est pour ça qu'on
mesure votre cuit mais ça veut dire qu'à
force entre astronautes vous êtes tous
savaient tous des très très gros qi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire et qu'est-ce
que ça qu'est ce que ça fait de ne
parlait quasiment qu'avec des gens qui
ont des groupes fuite
alors c'est justement une sélection mais
une fois les élections c'est les gens
qui sont tout à fait humain est tout à
fait normaux avec lesquels on peut avoir
des conversations extrêmement agréable
de des conversions que nous avons dans
l'espace ou même à l'entraînement ne
sont pas des conversations quantique
foule sur des choses extrêmement
complexe mais on oublie de faire des
tests depuis parce que c'est une
sélection donc il faut sélectionner sur
tous les critères que nous avons et
lorsque vous prenez un astronaute et
vous allez lui faire faire trois ou
quatre ans d'entraînement où il doit
apprendre
il va apprendre des systèmes
régulièrement passer des examens il vaut
mieux qu'il a un cerveau bien fait
adaptable et surtout n'ont fait pas des
cui classique on fait des cui timing
serre que fait les cuisses ou stress
c'est là que on donne à une personne
sans question sachant que dans le temps
imparti le plus intelligent intelligent
de fera que 50 questions on peut c'est
pour voir comment ils réagissent sous
stress avec des exercices intellectuels
important mais c'est comme ça que se
font aussi les vrais tests de qi 1c ils
ont limité dans le temps
de la même manière mais moi je discute
pas là elle est là la validité du test
je comprends très bien pour qu'on fêtait
ces tests là c'est la question que je me
pose c'est quand vous êtes les cinq là
qu'on a vu en photo / challenger on se
dit qu'ils ont tous des cui
supérieur très supérieur à la moyenne et
je me dis dans les rapports humains
qu'on peut avoir alors qu'ils sont
stress sous stress aussi parce qu'on est
dans l'espace mais il ya l'entraînement
avant on les a on a vécu avec eux
pendant longtemps voilà qu'est ce que ça
change d'être entre des gens qui ont des
gros cubes
est ce que ça change mais les blagues
qu'on se raconte on fait attention on se
raconte pas les mêmes
est ce que ça change la nature des
conversations non ça sens pas le bon
chaque personne je vois la photo de mon
équipage et je vois le bien aux cheveux
blancs steve hawley qu'était un
astrophysicien qui lui a lancé je crois
quatre cinq télescopes en fuite il
connaissait tout sur l'astrophysique
c'est un gars extrêmement calais donc
c'est vrai qu'avec lui on parlait de
choses
bon assez complexe au niveau
astrophysique mais il se trouve que
comme hobby il avait des chiens donc
très souvent et le matin ils nous
racontaient comment ces chiens avaient
passé la nuit comment très chiadé etc
on attendait des conversations tout à
fait classique avec ces gens là mais si
vous voulez le jour ouvré de questions
un peu complexe au niveau de
l'astrophysique et bien ils sont très
forts je viens de de steve hawley parce
que j'avais un problème sera
déprogrammée connaît quand la navette
d'école il ya plusieurs programmes
d'ordinateur il est en forme que j'avais
pas bien comprendre et d'expliquer de
façon extrêmement difficile dans les
livres et les instructeurs ne l'est pas
expliqué très très bien je posais la
question un matin je commençais d'au
mois sept heures du matin il m'a
expliqué ben c'est un c'est un programme
qui va accélérer le phénomène d'arriver
dans l'espace etc et s'est expliqué très
simple l'avantagé de ces gens là qui
sont hyper instruit intelligent c'est
que un système complexe ils vont de vous
l'expliquer de façon extrêmement simple
et vous allez le comprendre encore plus
rapidement que si vous avez passé des
heures et des heures demandées lire et
devant des simulateurs
oui ça c'est un petit peu ce que je peux
dire de ces personnes là ils sont ils
sont super entraîné donc il arrive à
condenser le vraiment le plus important
donc c'est assez agréable d'avoir des
gens qui vous résumer qui vont aller
droit au but
non je veux un bon rapport avec tous ces
gens là ils étaient des gens vraiment
extrêmement durable
on voit qu'il ya chez vous quelque chose
de profondément modeste c'est que vous
vous mettez pas dans le même club
et pourtant vous y êtes je m'imagine que
même si on leur pose la même question
sur une autre chaîne de télé ailleurs
dans le monde il raconterait la même
chose de vous or vous raconter dans
votre livre que vous étiez un très
mauvais élève à l'école c'était pas
doués du tout en fin du mois vous
n'aviez pas l'impression d'être doué
comme quoi alors bon j'ai eu un début
d'été dit parce que j'ai commencé en
afrique et les professeurs que j'avais à
l'époque ne venait pas souvent l'école
donc l'école était un petit peu libre 1
c'était vraiment une fois temps en temps
donc c'était décousu et j'avais du mal à
prendre bien sûr
et quand je suis rentré en france à
l'âge de 10 ans et c'est ce que
j'explique dans mon livre je tombe sur
un prof de maths qui m'a qui m'a
expliqué les maths avec régularité
et moi je suis quelqu'un qui a besoin de
régularité dans l'apprentissage et avec
ce prof de maths je sais pas c'est
vraiment premier en maths très
rapidement et je suis resté première map
après tout le temps et ça m'a aidé
beaucoup c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je
j'adresse un salut quand même important
à à nos enseignants parce c'est eux qui
tiennent un petit peu notre jeunesse
les enseignants peut faire de vous le
meilleur ou le pire et si vous tombez
sur un bon enseignant quel qu'il soit
prof de lettres porte de ma prof de
physique pour d'époque ce soir vous
allez vraiment décollé et il faut vous
êtes passé ce cap
eh bien vous êtes sûr d'être sur le bon
chemin mais si vous passez pas le cap
et bien c'est assez facile de tomber de
l'autre côté et c'est pour ça que je
pense que l'éducation c'est peut-être la
chose la plus importante que nous avons
à faire dans un peu mais cette dernière
question est ce que vous croyez aux
extraterrestres vous alors j'en ai pas
vu les failles terrestres temps au vol
je ne connais pas beaucoup d'astronautes
qui ont rencontré des ratés reste nous
avons observé des ovnis donc il ya des
objets non identifiés qui sont certaines
fois explicable certaines fois c'est le
vendredi soir le samedi soir après la
sortie des bistrots à c'était avant le
conflit manga sûr et puis il reste quand
même
à 30% de phénomènes inexpliqués sur
lequel nous cherchons donc nous
cherchons de plus en plus bien sûr nous
allons pas trouvé grand chose
aujourd'hui à part les exoplanètes on
n'a pas trouvé de petits hommes pères
qui flottent dans l'espace qui nous
quittent pas votre cas rôle lorsque vous
êtes dans la station spatiale
mais en moins par rapport à votre
enfance où la probabilité que les
extraterrestres existent était très
faible
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a découvert
énormément de planètes et galaxies
la probabilité qu'ils existent est
devenu très très forte ce serait quand
même aberrant que leur signé que nous
donc fatalement on se dit qu'il ya une
forme de vie quelque part on n'est pas
forcément pressés qu'ils arrivent chez
nous parce que ça veut dire qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus évoluée que nous beaucoup
plus forts technologiquement et que donc
ils auraient toutes les choses qui nous
colonisent s est facilement mes
meilleurs moins en théorie
il ya quand même toutes les chances
qu'ils existent non ça ce que vous dites
ça correspond tout à fait au paradoxe de
fermi qui est un astrophysicien italien
il dit que le soleil est une étoile qui
est né dans l'ensemble des milliards
d'état que nous sommes ni les premiers
et les derniers donc ceux qui sont nés
des milliards d'années avant nous s'il
avait eu un développement intégral comme
le nôtre eh bien il aurait pu déjà nous
rejoindre nous conquérir ou nous
expliquer où nous apprendre or ils sont
pas là et c'est la phrase de charme et
qui dit où sont ils donc c'est une
grande c'est une grande question où sont
ils et c'est vrai que sont-ils et est
aujourd'hui je pense qu'en tant que
scientifique on voit on doit rester
extrêmement prudent sur cette réponse
on doit chercher et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très important
tout le travail que nous avons fait de
la station spatiale qui va préparer les
systèmes qui rompt sur la lune le
travail son ami qui va préparer le
travail que nous faisons sur mars ils
sur mars on va essayer de creuser la
croûte martienne plutôt de l'eau liquide
sa voix est ce qu'il ya des bactéries
sur faire dans la danse oulad proche de
la couche de mars et savoir est ce que
les bactéries martienne on rassemble
bactéries terrestre donc c'est plein de
questions que nous devons faire et je
crois que nous astronautes comme les
scientifiques on doit être extrêmement
précautionneux sur ce plan là pour
avancer de façon solide sinon on tombe
dedans
dans l'obscurantisme qui est extrêmement
négatif merci michel tonini un café dans
l'espace et le titre de votre livre qui
vient de paraître aux éditions humaines
sciences merci d'avoir passé une heure
avec nous merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]